we are now going to look uh in this
segment and in the next segment at some
of the speeches at the turning point usa
student summit okay this was in tampa
florida now we're going to start with
donald trump's wwe style entrance to the
summit and i know that you're going to
see this and you're going to cringe and
when i see it i cringe but just remember
the left doesn't have anything like this
the right engages people with this stuff
it's so stupid and it's so fundamentally
vapid
but they fund stuff to activate people
they fund stuff to get people excited
and we just fail on the left take a look
at this introduction for trump
and i fight harder for you than any
president has ever fought again
we will win again we will win win win
you're fired
the
most are trump supporters because they
like it when people don't understand
what the americans are i think i'd be a
really good president
because you'll be in jail
i'm president and you're know
[Music]
and i fight harder for you than any
president has ever before thank you
[Applause]
we're going to make america great again
i love you thank you thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the 45th president of the
united states of america
donald j
trump
[Music]
okay and there's pyrotechnics going and
eventually trump comes out so listen
it's a complete and total joke but they
know how to engage people they're
getting young people engaged and unless
the left figures out how to fund stuff
like this and how to effectively
coalesce people
around candidates and ideas uh it's not
looking particularly good now on the
substance the speech that trump gave to
the turning point usa people was
completely unhinged at one point trump
said he wanted to give himself the
congressional medal of honor
in fact as president i wanted to give
myself the congressional medal of honor
but they wouldn't let me do it
they wouldn't let me do it i said i'm
going to give myself a i've always
wanted that
but they wouldn't let me do that they
said that would be inappropriate i said
okay it would look bad for trump to do
that one of the most uh stunning things
trump will sometimes do is he will tell
stories about flying on private jets
either his own or air force one and uh
not exactly relatable to most people in
the crowd but trump's audience here in
florida sat silently as trump told the
bizarre rambling story about air force
one just really not reading the room you
can't believe it you know air force one
is actually two planes it's two big
747s
so they were ordered
but we're on the plane flying over
and we're about an hour away from the
big airfield that we're landing in in
iraq
and i get a
call and then some military people came
in to see me you know this is like a a
large home
air force one very big a lot of people
on the plane most talented people you've
ever seen including the pilots the most
incredible people
sir
would you please do us a favor we'd like
to close all of your windows i say why
we don't want any light on the plane i
said why is that because we don't want
the enemy to see us think of it we've
been there for 20 years and we can't fly
an airplane into the contract
i said that's pretty sad so they closed
down all of the shades everything was
absolutely dark then they said sir we're
going to be turning off the lights and
the plane i said what do you have to do
that we just closed all the shades and
the windows he really has a way with
words i mean just a riveting absolutely
riveting storyteller as you can see
um donald trump claimed that nursing
home residents really don't don't vote
that much because they're very busy
dying wisconsin they said nursing home
the nursing home scandal nursing homes
typically don't vote too much you know
people are dying
they got other things in their mind
but they got almost a hundred percent of
the people in nursing homes so trump
very confused about what goes on in
nursing homes and then trump began
playing up the victim stuff saying he's
the most persecuted person in american
history again another part of the speech
that the crowd was silent during a
friend of mine recently said
that i was the most persecuted person in
the history of our country me the most
persecuted i never thought it that way i
never had time i was always fighting
with these people that were trying to
persecute me
i didn't have time to think about being
persecuted because i was fighting
persecution
when i thought about it though i sit
back he's a very smart guy successful
i thought set back i said you know
he may very well be right
certainly there's been no politician or
president treated like i've been treated
right no one's been treated worse than
trump as he continues to remind us then
the christian nationalist moment of the
speech we're going to talk about this
more tomorrow in general the republican
party going in this christian
nationalist direction trump again with
this americans kneel before god and god
alone we will not break we will not
yield we will never give in
we will never give up
we will never ever ever back down
as long as we are confident in united
the tyrants we are fighting
do not stand a chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and god alone
right
and that is another allusion to the
christian nationalism of the modern
republican party and then trump capping
off his speech to these young
conservatives
with uh some transphobia that's a big
part now of every uh trump speech you
can't teach the bible but you can teach
children that america is evil and that
men can get pregnant a man can get
pregnant
[Applause]
can't even talk about the bible you
would not trust these people to babysit
your children for 20 minutes
and why should we then
let them educate millions of american
students six hours a day year after year
after year and then also trump uh
misgendering trans people and goading
the crowd into booing them this is
another staple of the trump speech
in a very sad state it already is our
country's never been in a position like
this before happened all in a short
period of time
across the united states we need to
implement strict prohibitions on
teaching inappropriate racial
sexual and political material to
america's children in any form
[Applause]
we will also keep men out of women's
sports is that okay
right
notice how fired up the crowd gets i
mean they've convinced these people in
the crowd
that that transports issue is like an
issue of paramount importance in the
united states
keep men out of lemons
think about it
[Applause]
now i've told the story a number of
times you know the
swimmer with a man's body you know they
say that they describe it that way they
say
no he's on the swim team he was given
women athlete of the year
so
oh you didn't hear i guess see so pretty
pretty sick stuff and very interesting
that now
interesting and disgusting that now the
transphobia is just a staple of when
trump speaks to crowds so
we will pause there
you can fi if you're if you're so
inclined you can find all these clips on
our instagram at david pakman show after
the break we'll look at what some of the
other speakers said and we need to be
this these events can't be ignored
because as sick as they are
the right knows exactly what they're
doing and the left is doing nothing so
we'll be right back with more from tampa
florida
let's talk about vpn's virtual private
networks even if you're using incognito
mode on your browser if you're not using
a vpn everything you do online can be
recorded by your internet provider and
that is permanent because they're
selling it search engines social media
companies are also tracking your every
move you only need one thing to protect
yourself from all of it private internet
access one of our sponsors it's a vpn
it's simple you take a moment and you
download it you turn it on and you're
protected and you stay protected and
that's it vpns can also keep your
connection secure from hackers important
every time you check your bank account
or 401k or pension otherwise it can all
be out in the open private internet
access never records or stores user data
they've even proven this policy multiple
times in court their software is open
source to show that there's no data
being logged
this transparency is why private
internet access
is the vpn i use and my audience gets 82
off so you can stay protected for just
two dollars and 11 cents a month plus
you'll get three months free go to
privateinternetaccess.com
pacman the link is down below